chloe kim i knew you was gonna be
successful you know why because you have
two kardashian names
in your name
the only advice i can give you watch out
for them tristan's that's all i got to
say
watch out for lil rel howery because
he's taking no prisoners
and by no prisoners we really just mean
tristan thompson watch out for them
tristan's that's all i got to say
yeah i said it y'all thinking it
the playful dig went down at the 2022
espys lil rel chillin in the audience on
sports biggest night next to some
top-tier athletes like chloe kim an
olympic gold medalist in snowboarding
but it's her name chloe and last name
kim yeah like the kardashians that
inspires lil rel to crack a joke you
have two kardashian names
in your name
the only advice i can give you watch out
for them tristan's that's all i got to
say
yeah i said it y'all thinking it
and when e.t spoke to the comedian on
the red carpet before the show he teased
something was coming i'm doing something
special on the show so tune in it's
gonna be really fun hopefully i hope
everybody laughs and like it was it
rehearsal went well so we'll see
it's gonna be fun
of course the mini tristan roast comes
just one week after a rep for khloe
kardashian confirmed to e.t the former
couple is expecting their second child
via surrogate
it's a wish chloe's expressed for a
while
i don't know true's getting older and i
just feel like it's now
time
to have another kid
yup
i like to hear
the only issue well the timeline
cause if you do the math seems coco and
tristan likely decided to go for baby
number two before the nba star was
caught cheating again i wanted to
believe that tristan could change i
wanted to trust him
yeah earlier this year tristan admitted
he fathered a baby boy with fitness
model marylee nichols
and no one was more upset than chloe's
sister kim the whole thing that's so sad
is she wants a baby boy and [ __ ] now
this girl's having a baby boy random
that he sleeps with one night
him oh i was so team him but seems the
drama is now behind them and their main
focus raising their four-year-old
daughter true and baby boy on the way
a source told et earlier this week chloe
and tristan's relationship is strained
but tolerable enough at this point chloe
and tristan communicate and are on the
same page in terms of doing things for
true and not together as a couple
still we're told tristan's telling his
friends he's excited about the newest
little one on the way his fourth but
chloe's inner circle isn't trusting
anything he says
i was nine months pregnant
when you cheated
if i wasn't pregnant i would have picked
you up so i just didn't want to break my
nails before delivery
shout out to the nails
as far as coco and tristan reconciling
we're not holding our breath
last month et learned the good american
founder is dating a private equity
investor after being set up by kim
why not
and we're told tristan isn't trying to
win coco back he's doing his own thing
while single which was on full display
earlier this week when the athlete was
snapped vacationing and holding hands
with a mystery woman in greece
you just have to
deal with it it is what it is yeah it's
no sweat for chloe our source says she
doesn't care about her ex stepping out
with other women as long as tristan
continues to be a good father to her
children that's all that matters
[Music]
you